the Donald Trump Russia connections
continue to grow we've talked about the
Trump cabinet Russia connections and
those also continue to grow the UH Trump
cabinet continues to become something
that very clearly is not going to make
America great again for the average
American here's what we already knew
okay so for people who I need to get up
to speed on what we already knew number
one Exxon CEO Rex Tillerson who is
slated to be Donald Trump Secretary of
State built his net worth of roughly two
hundred million dollars on the backs of
destroying the planet through oil
drilling and he is going to be the top
surrogate for Donald Trump around the
world he has ties to Russian President
Vladimir Putin those ties go back almost
two decades under Taylor sins leadership
Russia became exons single biggest
exploration theater as the company
amassed drilling rights across tens of
millions of acres and in 2011 on behalf
of ExxonMobil Tillerson signed an
agreement with Russia for drilling in
the Arctic which could be valued at up
to 300 million billion dollars rather
fortunately that agreement has not been
carried out so far because of sanctions
enacted against Russia obviously the
question is with Tillerson remove those
sanctions against Russia and as a little
cherry on top three years ago in 2013
Rex Tillerson was awarded the order of
friendship by Vladimir Putin Vladimir
Putin the greatest geopolitical foe of
the United States according to Mitt
Romney in 2012 officially calling
Trump's incoming secretary of state part
of the order of friendship of Russia
okay that's the background what's the
latest news the latest news is insane
newly need a leaked documents show I
it's up it's this seems almost fake Pat
newly leaked documents show that Rex
Tillerson the soon-to-be secretary of
state of the u.s. is the director of an
American Russian oil company based in
the tax haven of the Bahamas something
that Donald Trump promised to punish as
president of the United States so Exxon
has a Russian subsidiary named Neff the
gas and tillerson has been the director
of NAFTA gas since 1990
an anonymous source leaked these
documents to a German newspaper now to
preempt the defenses were going to hear
from the trumpets no one is saying this
is illegal because it's not but it
raises even more questions about the
selection of Rex Tillerson is the top
American diplomat of the United States
in a time when the FBI and CIA agree
that Russia hacked the u.s. to help
Trump win the Secretary of State
selected by the beneficiary of Russian
hacking Donald Trump has decade-long
ties to Russia and directs a Russian oil
company and oh by the way Pat again they
are using a tax haven of the Bahamas to
avoid paying taxes on profits the Trump
campaign for more than a year talked
about punishing companies that are using
tax havens to avoid paying taxes on
profits here is a joint us-russian
venture that your own Secretary of State
is running that is using one of those
tax havens I'm sure they're gonna be
punished any day right and this is
really no surprise I mean Rex Tillerson
for a long time now has tried to
sidestep the state department's policy
yep towards making deals with the Kurds
towards the Russians towards the
Venezuelans and now you have even
big-name republicans coming against this
pic like Marco Rubio John McCain et
cetera guys I thought Trump was going to
drain the swamp this is not exactly
drain in the swamp this is filling the
swamp with a fire hose every single one
of these pics is bad for Americans but
maybe i I just I keep getting confused
Pat if we're friends with Russia now I
guess I don't need to be worried about
this I mean they help pick our
presidents and all that great stuff
maybe I just need to change my view
about Russia and embrace this amazing
and really really great partnership
it'll be really good for rural
mississippians for example to have Rex
Tillerson running a Russian oil company
while being Secretary of State yet now
we're draining the swamp we no longer
have politicians in these State
Department diplomatic rules yeah well
that's I I'm glad you brought that up
because that's another defense we're
going to hear from the trumpets which is
David listen when you stop appointing
career politicians to positions of power
and instead you bring in people who were
successful from what they call the real
world although 200 million dollar net
worth is not exactly the real world for
most people that I know uh you're
inherently going to have perceived
conflicts but these are just really good
people really good successful people are
going to have connections to all sorts
of people all over the world that's why
they're successful and it's good of
course it's a total fantasy world
mentality but I know that the trumpets
they they have to say it because they
can't admit they voted for the wrong
person and then there's this faulty idea
that they've made their money and now
they're going to turn around and try to
make it for the United States instead
all right yeah yeah uh Tillerson has is
200 million now that's over now it's all
about making money for for like I said
the average rural Mississippi enter or
the average urban Detroit resident or
whatever term you want to use its bogus
the swamp is being filled do not kid
yourselves